[Music]
thank you ladies and gentlemen
here's the thing you guys might have
been listening to the friendship onion
before and thank you if you have and
thank you for coming this is the first
ever live uh
friendship onion podcast
and you guys are here the first ever
so you guys are kind of creating this
thing because beforehand it's just been
me and billy and johnny clues and he's a
terrible audience member and it's
absolutely awful to be honest he's yeah
yeah he just drinks a glass of wine and
eats nuts yeah
really uh but thank you thank you so
much and fingers crossed because we're
doing a few more
podcasts not podcasts yeah live well
yeah podcast but conventions we'll be
doing more podcasts at the convention so
maybe we'll see
another one yeah travel around it's good
but the main thing is you saw the very
first one and
and and one day dom will be dead
and and
pretty soon actually and maybe me but i
hope not and we can all get together and
talk about how we saw the first one to
be honest i feel half dead i um
i didn't have breakfast this morning and
just over there
i very quickly drank a can of red bull
don't you
i'm not sure if my heart can take it it
was watching you dance might have just
pushed me over the edge there i'm one of
the great dancers what an ass you've got
thank you
i'm going to start with a dance story
and lord of the rings oh brilliant wait
till you hear this you know there's a
scene in louder rings has anyone ever
seen lord of the rings the trilogy
[Applause]
i was going to guess that the guy in the
cloak and the lady in the elf ears
probably has
but um there's a scene in it where
me and dom what pub are we in it's like
rohana you guys are no better than us
probably all right is that where we're
getting told off by gandalf yeah so
gandalf's watching us on a table dancing
and uh and we're just having a great
time you know we've found this little
place
and where we can you know people are
giving us beer and we're just having a
good time
and
it was actually fran walsh if you
remember was directing that
and she said look we have to get this
right otherwise pete
wouldn't put it in the movie you know
so we were trying to work out a kind of
fun thing
and i remember um
my wife hey
a dog
jeez i got afraid of that he's going to
be attacked by an outstation wow
tiny tiny little dog fearful of cameras
but my wife who was my wife's girlfriend
at that time she was a dancer and she
told me how she used to like when she
was very young the the the dance class
used to make them go from one end to the
other doing high kicks and she used to
do it and it used to make me laugh a lot
and i thought i'm going to do that in
this scene
so if you remember and this is visual so
not very good for a podcast but good for
the live podcast um she i did this and
the thing and it was directly stolen
do a dance don't pull your hamstring
i also think
i think there's like a little clip out
there of billy and i doing this but i'm
not sure if you guys have any context of
it but when we were doing rehearsals
you and i stumbled upon
a kind of
like
three stoogey physical thing where we
were like twisting each other's boobs oh
yeah slapping each other's asses and you
know ducking underneath each other's
legs i think we so we were doing like
sword fencing and hanging out all day
and then billy and i started doing some
physical thing which ended up turning
into like a good 20 to 30 seconds of
stuff i wonder if maybe pete and fran
had started to know about those things
and thought i'll
you came up with a really nice thing in
that day as well i did actually i don't
know what it is yeah you know when we're
doing people dance with our hands and
stuff and he says we've got big giant
feet he said i would think that hobbits
probably use their feet when they're
dancing so we did the sort of little
almost bavarian slap but with our feet
yeah which is really fun
peeling the onion
or should we do some housekeeping
how much fun are you doing
i'm looking through my notes
oh you've got all the housekeeping
housekeeping i also have reading glasses
i went so i really admire uh billy's
reading glasses he's always not only
just billy got great reading glasses but
because he always loses stuff he has a
lot of different reading glasses because
he's always like having to replace him
and a few uh weeks ago i was like man
i'm having reading glasses envy i'm
going to go to the optician or as they
say in
the united states the optometrist oh
that's a bit of neat and uh i went and
the guy said i'm sorry to say but you
have um absolutely perfect vision you
don't need glasses yeah i was like i'll
kick a cat i wanted some glasses
he apologized for that did he did yeah
trouble because he wasn't getting any
cash yeah but remember i said i said to
him i said well if i wear glasses
uh with just glass in will it make my
eyes get worse because i want my eyes to
get worse so they can wear glasses you
went no that's a myth you can wear
glasses with glass in and it doesn't
affect your eyes and i said if
yeah there was something else oh uh if
you uh if you start wearing glasses with
a prescription would that make them will
that will that take you down the slope
quite quickly you said no that's also a
myth i said can you punch me in my eyes
so that
i can start wearing reading glasses and
he said now
anyway put them on wow you look so sexy
so here we go i was reading this one and
i thought maybe you could help out emily
from location unknown how's that
location unknown i always meant to ask
that with johnny closes
yeah he probably just lost the email
but anyway
emily says on a recent episode dom
mentioned the dreaded fungus gnat oh and
how once you get them all your house
plants will be dead within six months
well
i've been battling fungus gnats for nine
months now and i won't give up i've
treated my houseplants twice
i have about like gifts and bananas and
stuff i don't know just she's definitely
treated them i don't know what what
she said she's got about 25 houseplants
but sadly this morning she's discovered
that resurgence of gnats in one
particular area
made the difficult decision to sacrifice
two of her plan
oh sophie's choice
in an attempt to save the rest
the
the third treatment is on the way wish
me luck have you get any any help here
dom
i'll be very quick here because i'm i
feel like we're losing the audience to
be honest
everybody likes to know about a nap so
fungus
fungus gnats are obviously you know live
in the wild if fg's yes if they get into
your house they eat uh
wet
or or sodden uh
organic matter soil and obviously when
you're watering a plant in your house
the the water can't go too many places
apart from into the roots of the plants
and then it saturates the soil so the
fungus gnats will eat the roots at the
end of the day and make a real mess of
your plants and ultimately kill them
what you can get emily is that right yes
it is emily
is a thing called mosquito bits break
that zone everywhere mosquito bits
because uh mosquito lava living stagnant
still water can't be running and if you
put these mosquito bits into you know
your pond or a waterfall or something
but like a pond or a lake it will kill
the uh mosquito lava and it will also
kill the fungus gnats and i also read
because i have fungus gnats as well that
if you if you use a diluted solution of
hydrogen peroxide and some water and use
that to water your plant it will kill
them she said she had a recent
resurgence i would guess that she
recently watered her plants because the
fungus net eggs will sit there in stasis
as it were which is a latin word
stillness stillness and then when you
water the plants uh the fungus gnats
come out they only live uh uh like a
week or so and they don't harm you but
my god they get on your nerves
well that has tremendous knowledge well
thanks yeah that you keep all that and
your brain is amazing yeah well i'm i
think the things that you're obsessed
about you you um you don't even need to
necessarily remember you just have
access to like you with guitars you have
a lot of information about guitars that
you're just able to access because
you're so because you're interested in
it and i'm i'm a little bit like that
with uh
in general good good i hope you've
learned a lot there yeah there you go
should we should we do one more question
go on um i think which is the best one
here
oh okay i'll have a bath question this
is for you william oh i love about it
and as a show of hands with the audience
this would be great for an audio podcast
as well
who enjoys a lovely soapy bath
well i would say more than half of the
audience yeah but half a yeah
yeah great i can't i can't i can't i
can't do it i feel dirty i feel like
clean no
i'm less clean than when i got in no
this comes from jen in denver colorado
we'll be in denver sometime soon won't
we dom
yeah i'll go on
f my hand yeah hold on i always get
confused since somebody changed it
that one
that one i love that the audience no
they're like no billy no no
it's incorrect
if my hand is a map of the united states
of america
over here we have california yeah up
here we have new york yeah this here
florida yeah
[Applause]
gatorland
[Applause]
where is denver colorado i'm gonna i'm
gonna guess here i'm gonna say denver's
around about
here
that was halfway down billy's wedding
finger that's the first time you've ever
got it right
you guys give me strength anyway
thanks jen from denver colorado said tom
in the beginning of one episode you made
some noise about billy filling the tub
in the hotel without a wipe down but
then you talked about using the remote
control first do you know the remote
control is one of the dirtiest things in
the hotel do you wipe them down just
curious it's not a question about that
it's a question about a remote control
which
yeah and and the bath and wiping down
i'd like to get something straight when
she says uh get in the bath before a
wipe down
wiping yourself down the bathroom all
right
yeah
but i am i am still quite surprised that
you don't give it just
just a little wipe down you think it's
self-cleaning the bath don't you well i
don't really know i don't even really
think about i get so excited when i get
in a hotel
that and i see a bath i just fill it up
and i get in it
actually making me feel a little um
a little sad because
well no because the remote control in
our hotel room
over the last couple of nights
had a slight stickiness to
i
it
and in my mind i thought someone's been
eating jolly ranchers
it probably wasn't jolly ranchers the
stickiest of candy yeah is sticky yeah
you should always give that away i don't
wipe down the uh remote control and
probably the um
the whole menu section of the
hotel room as well probably the whole
thing if you think i just don't think
about it well supposedly i'm sure you
guys know but supposedly in those like
you know true crime documentaries when
they go into a hotel room with a uv
light yeah blue light which shows uh
let's just say
bodily exclusions
it's like a jackson pollock painting
everywhere the ceilings
i mean someone's written help me on the
ceiling
i've even written that with you know
anyway we'll move on see i'll go back to
when i used to have bath as a young
child yes right because i think this is
where i started to really enjoy it there
was a show on tv called the man from
atlantis yeah an underwater man aquatic
he had gills didn't it yeah he was in
dallas i remember that was it but yeah
the actor was you remember that the man
from atlantis and he could breathe
underwater brilliant i get a round of
applause for remembering our tv show
magic
but i absolutely believed i could
breathe underwater
i used to go under and go
i'm breathing
with that done
as if i'd gills or something
and i think from that day on the joy of
being in a bath has stayed with me
since starting to incorporate magic
spoon into my daily morning routine i've
noticed fewer cravings throughout the
day and more energy to hold me over
until lunchtime we're all trying to eat
better of course but a healthy breakfast
doesn't have to be boring magic spoon
has the most amazing flavors you love
but without all the bad stuff and it's
really fantastic as a midnight snack
right before bed i've been drinking
protein shakes after the gym all the
time but i finally found a delicious way
to get my protein before and after
workouts dom let me give you some
numbers because these facts are very
impressive
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving the
honey nut flavor has one gram of sugar
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and it's low carb you can build your own
box there are nine available flavors to
build your very own custom bundle and
they are cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter cookies and cream maple waffle
blueberry muffin cinnamon roll and honey
nut and even more exciting magic spoon
has just brought back their cereal bars
they were so popular that they brought
them back permanently it's the perfectly
convenient on-the-go companion for your
cereal go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and be sure to use the promo
code onion at checkout to save five
dollars off your order and magic spin is
so confident in their product it's back
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason that refund your money no
questions asked remember go get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com onion and use the code
onion to save five dollars off thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
oh
i love that sound
that is the sound of another sale on
shopify the all-in-one commerce platform
to start run and grow your business
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so upstarts startups and establish
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility and i love how shopify has
the tools and resources that make it
easy for any business to succeed from
down the street to around the globe
shopify powers millions of businesses
from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
all lowercase for a free 14 14-day trial
and get full access to shopify's entire
suite of features grow your business
with shopify today go to shopify.com
onion right now shopify.com
onion well lovely what next should we do
one more question should we do a tongue
twister should we do a question i like
dom riddle i sent you this morning
because i found it on housekeeping
and i quite liked uh this because i
thought you would maybe have a good idea
um hold on and it's from the uk and it's
sarah
from lincoln
where's lincoln
fair enough
it says i understand you're both huge
star wars fans if you could switch one
character from star wars and one
character from lord of the rings and
drop them in that universe who do you
think would be the funniest or slash
most badass workover
good question
thank you today is a big question oh
it's a big question it's a whole you
know it's two whole universities yeah
well funniest or
badass i mean
would you put jar jar binks on anything
wonder what gandalf would think of him
yeah
i mean vader's obviously the big badass
in the star wars universe i mean him him
going up against sauron would be kind of
fun it became on his side though
wouldn't he would they i think so aren't
they both like no it's my evil it's not
your ego i think the outside star said i
don't know i've made a check
and a multiverse yeah true um
i don't know i mean yoda would obviously
be fun in a crossover thing and then
with our guys
when they are starting to do crossovery
stuff right i know marvel's done a lot
of crossover stuff and not wanting to
spoil stuff but i did like accidentally
spoil yeah you did a doctor strange
thing for billy the other day which i
thought was brilliant i didn't mean it
no i didn't i actually said have you
seen the new doctor strange he said no i
said something happens that's kind of
interesting do you want to know and
billy said yeah go on tell me and then
when i told him he went oh would you
tell me that for
are you going to tell them
you guys probably no no i won't i won't
you guys probably know already as well
um
i would like to see i'd like to see
aragon
and and this star wars story
but you know when he got there he really
likes his sword aragon doesn't he talks
about it all the time in that
server but i bet if he arrived you know
and like ewan mcgregor was there to meet
him
and the
landing port
when you go from one universe to another
yeah
and you know mcgregor says you know oh
how that's what sword is that you have
anything dragon yeah this is not the
sword you're looking for
yeah and uh you know aragorn would tell
him about how his father's grandfather
and then named them all yeah and all the
swords that went before yeah but then
ewan mcgregor would just like
[Music]
be like well this is a sword but it's uh
really really really really hot
[Laughter]
yeah
i'll have one of those hot sauces
yeah you would i think they'd be great
mates those two new obi-wan kenobi show
coming out uh pretty soon right
looking good it's looking good hey we
have a riddle should we do a very quick
riddle because it's a quick one i love
red
this is a this is only a it's the first
two word riddle you've ever had amazing
someone sent this
ready go dog
little number she actually sent five
riddles but i'll just give him
five there's no time for fight all right
we're riddle one ready
right oh did you send them oh was it you
oh hi here's yellow paper all right
little one
ready bills yeah
a candle
go on that's it
read it again go on you have to answer
it right
candle
oh sorry those are the answers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's an easy mistake to make dumb what
what shall i do should i do the riddle
and see if
it makes sense now
so sorry about that
oh god yeah it makes sense now when i
think about it
yeah
you measure my life in hours
i serve you by expiring i'm quick when
i'm thin i'm slow and i'm fat the wind
is my enemy what am i
set up
well it's a kind of yeah
all right here we go um give you one of
these
um
okay
turn me on my side
this sounds like me last night after a
couple of glasses of wine
turn me on my side and i am everything
hello
cut me in half and i am nothing oh dear
what am i
i'll give you one more give us on the
save turn me on my side on everything
everything got me in half and i have
nothing
did you look at the answer yeah because
i mean i asked the question all right
what was the end again what was the last
thing
this is a good one what's your name my
darling
raven this is a great are we a minute oh
go on here hang on a second on your
everything
nothing in half no
what was the last sentence again
caught me in my half i am nothing
and then there was something after that
wasn't that yeah what am i
[Laughter]
that's not the riddle part
that is the that is the part no the
riddles the bit before the last bits
just the question all right
oh anybody get any clues sites oh just
so wait a minute
there's something
but worked out today
hey
she's got it come on my god thanks daddy
[Applause]
fantastic work and you win absolutely
nothing but
what's your name my love so we can put
it out there
logan got it fantastic work logan and
thank you raven for these riddles that's
brilliant do you remember a sci-fi show
called logan's run
[Applause]
can i get a round of applause for that
please red hat
thank you this gentleman the red hat
likes to uh give me a round of applause
when i remember a tv show nice brilliant
thank you
well
i mean are we doing a tongue twister
we've got a few tongue twisters here
okay i've done a warm-up of you
no i'm not no no
oh hang on okay look at that john
my goodness
see i don't know if you've noticed but
my name is uh
it's not an alliteration is it bb
yeah that's alliteration yeah
alliteration so that's got a lot of bees
in it so let's do it you do it slowly
build so everyone knows what we're
trying to do okay we're doing this brisk
breathe brigadiers brandish broad bright
blades
blunderbussies and blungeons balling
some them badly
beautifully red well they're classically
trained
i'm gonna pick you up on it's gonna pick
you up on one thing there yeah it's
bludgeon not blunden
if you say blungen three times it's
incorrect bludgeon bludgeon great
bludgeons
i'm going to pick you up for everything
yeah i do
be pedantic peter uh who's first you're
you or i i would say you have a go but
i'm going to make logan in charge of
making sure that we do it correctly
absolutely because sometimes i think dom
says he did it correctly when he didn't
really no i think i always get it right
three times yeah
the best of the three you're on the
check what's your name sir
mike is on the timer dom i'm going to
give you three two one and you go on
goal you don't go on one
that's another thing in a in american
sports
when they they go on three one two three
bulls well that's on four isn't it
that's on bulls
yeah three two one go risk brave
brigadiers brandish broad bright blades
blunderblosses and bludgeons balancing
them badly
three times
all right right right i'm sorry sorry
i'm sorry mike i mean that was a test
well we're going to restart all right
three times in a row but you only get
three goals at it yeah it's because it
was and that's one of your goals okay
fair enough
fair
enough give me a three two one go
a three two one go brisk brave
brigadiers brandish broad bright blades
blunderblasters and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blaze
blunderblasters and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blaze
blunderblasters and bludgeons balancing
them badly
logan said no
it's billy boyd's audience now
[Laughter]
are you ready this is the last go
three two one go brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blades
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blades
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
them badly wrists brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blaze
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
the badly very good job
that's the hard one
logan says yes what was it
20 seconds
what's 20 divided by three
six point six six six recurring seconds
in
infinity on its save yeah
[Laughter]
all right bills you
ready ready yep
three two one go bruce oh oh nice peters
it doesn't count it doesn't count
give you that one no it doesn't count
yeah i know
okay
ready yeah
three two one go brisk breathe
brigadiers brandy sprod bright blades
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broad bright blades
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
brandish broadbright blades blender
[ __ ] and bludgeons balancing them
badly
19 seconds
first time he's ever won a tongue
twister competition
can anyone beat it yeah does anyone
think that is anyone a magnificent the
first hand that went up did we go for
first hand think it was that gentleman
that gentleman there he is like a
tongue-twisting champion by the looks of
things would you like to come up to the
mic here sir and this right here right
here with the beard
here he comes here it comes
[Applause]
introduce yourself you look like a young
wolverine
thank you yeah you're welcome
um what's your name sir my name is chase
i don't have an accent but i found that
if you read this in an accent much like
billy's oh it goes faster it was even
better
all right that's a good accent as well
are you ready yeah do i go three times
or one three three times sir
yeah and logan's right behind you
and she don't take no shaders
ready
a three two one go brisk brave
brigadiers brandish broad bright blades
blonder bosses and bludgeons balancing
them badly brisk brave brigadiers
british broad bright blades blunder
bosses and bludgeons balancing them
badly brisk brave brigadiers brandish
broadbright blades blonder bosses and
bludgeons balancing them badly my
[Applause]
that was god
hold on before you sit down we haven't
checked with logan oh it's a hundred she
loved it she loved it
mike
what was the official time
14 seconds we have professionals i know
amazing the only one that i can do
really fast is the pheasant one and
someone actually came up to me at the uh
convention the other day and just swore
directly in my face because of it do you
know you know the pheasant one i'm not a
pheasant blocker my person pluck a son
and i'm only blocking pheasants of a
pheasant comes someone came over to the
convention and just went tater tater
taters
oh what's going on oh sorry i'm trying
to do a tongue twister oh right okay i
get it
ever heard of data brokers they're the
middlemen collecting and selling all
those digital footprints you leave
online they can stitch together detailed
profiles which include your browsing
history online searches and location
data they then sell your profile off to
a company who delivers you a targeted
act
no biggie right well you might be
surprised to learn that these same data
brokers are also selling your
information to the department of
homeland security and the irs i for one
don't want the tax man showing up at my
door because of some search i did on my
phone so to mask your digital footprints
i protect myself with expressvpn
when you're connected to expressvpn your
ip address is hidden that makes it much
more difficult for data brokers to
identify who you are expressvpn also
encrypts 100
of network traffic to keep your data
safe from hackers on public wi-fi that's
why i have expressvpn app downloaded in
all my devices phone computer even my
home wi-fi router all i do is tap one
button turn it on and i'm protected it's
that easy so make sure your online
activity and data is protected with the
best vpn money can buy visit
expressvpn.com right now and get three
extra months free through our special
link that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
onion
expressvpn.com to learn more
the conqueror teamed up with warner
brothers consumer products and designed
five iconic virtual challenges to take
everyone from the enchanting bag end to
the unknown depths of mordor the
conqueror virtual challenges was
designed in 2016 to help solve one of
the biggest problems that many people
face in their lives starting and
sticking to regular exercise to enhance
and maintain health and well-being and
it's working so far the conqueror has
helped over 400 000 people globally who
says sports and fantasy don't have a lot
in common so
how does it work dom i'll tell you billy
scan the qr code and download the
conqueror challenges app join the first
challenge using your unique codes and
don't stop until you reach mordor follow
the same path as the fellowship and go
through the five trails in the same
order the shire the fellowship minds of
moria the eye of sauron and mordor walk
run cycle or do any activity to advance
on the middle earth map enjoy stories
and postcards every time you reach a
milestone get five beautifully crafted
medals for each challenge completed and
help the one ring travel from
mesmerizing hobbiton to dreadful mount
doom follow frodo's epic journey through
middle earth with the lord of the rings
virtual challenge series walk run or
cycle all the way from the shire to
mount doom in an epic adventure with one
goal destroying the one ring you can
track all your miles or kilometers
across middle earth directly in the
mobile ios and android apps you can
enter an activity into the app manually
by entering its distance or by syncing
your activities from your favorite
fitness tracker or smart watch
you can only arrive at mount doom by
having the courage to complete each
challenge in
sequential order
only those with the determination and
bravery to see the journey through to
its end will be able to claim the final
medal once you complete the previous
challenge you'll be able to start the
next one
well that's fantastic bills now hey
where can listeners go to find it well
that's simple dom the app can be found
at the conqueror dot events forward
slash onion that's t h e
c o n q u e r o r dot
events slash o n i o n
the conqueror dot events slash
onion are we done with the tongue
twisters i think so because i'm sweating
oh yeah i always i get really excited at
tongue twisters
i think because that was all bees yeah
maybe
my
kind of struggle with the tongue twister
is in the b arena
whereas i'm
slightly better at ones you know that
are like in an f
which is ironic because you love these i
do love these and you love honey yeah
billy and dom eat the world
what we're doing now dumb it's confusing
isn't it it's not that good well we
don't have johnny clues telling us what
to do so i would say it's time for
billions on to eat the world
now we've got an idea for this one
yes we we uh really tried to lean into
the floridian uh lifestyle
and choose a couple of
controversials cakes well well here's
what happened
we read
on the internet
that um a fellow called
ron desantis
governor ron desantis signs a bill to
officially designate strawberry
shortcake as the state dessert
well we we
we don't live in florida but we thought
we thought key lime pie right
but then we read on further
and uh this i say ron desantis
okay
[Applause]
but it says the official designation is
a tribute to florida strawberry farmers
and i thought that's quite nice
yeah but what about florida's uh line uh
but the florida um farmers strawberry
farmers produce 75 of the winter
strawberry crop of the united states
that's three quarters though
and the governor signed ability law at
the strawberry festival held every year
at plant city florida now
so me and dom thought well we
we don't really have
a cow in this fight is that what you see
i'm not sure it's a cow i mean
i think cows are for milking aren't they
really is it
you know it's a dog a dog in the face
look at the little dog that was woofing
earlier he's so sweet just sat there
looking imagine a coffee
if you can
you know
cows have no idea just how powerful they
actually are yeah well you could yeah
because
cows are super strong yeah of course i'm
not talking about bulls here which are
obviously known for being strong but
like cows do kill
quite a lot of humans do they yeah they
do they'll trample a human well they
yeah
cows i believe killed more well i know
cows kill more humans in a year than
sharks
and sharks get such a bad rap oh you
know i heard two amazing facts about
sharks
i thought you especially would love i
love them you're all about you know
cosmic stuff right
the animal the shark
is older
than trees
on planet earth it has been around
longer than trees
that's an amazing fact as it is but this
is go on he's got some thoughts
when when was the first tree
damn it
well i know sharks have been around
sharks have been around for
over 200 million years you know 220 230
million years right trees are obviously
younger than that but here's a here's
the cosmic one for you okay sharks have
been around longer than the rings of
saturn
my goodness should we eat some cake
i thought i think we'll need to we need
to now won't in that amazing amazing
fact isn't it yeah incredible where is
the cake
there's there's going to be two cakes
dom
because not only are we going to eat the
world today but we're going to eat two
worlds
interesting
because we're gonna we're gonna work out
if florida's national pudding
uh dessert should be the key lime pie or
the strawberry shop well let's see
has anyone got cakes for us
ah here we go cakes
oh thanks thank you so much
thank you
thank you
there we are
that's a lot
first thing dom 10 points if you know
which one is which aha
thank you very much really um yes what
well billy printed out some information
about me
not about me
i do often print out information about
dom and i read it before i go to sleep
again
john was born in manchester moving
i was born in berlin that's a disgrace
um
that's this next um so billy printed out
some pages about these cakes and stuff
not another thing that doesn't
necessarily work on a video podcast but
first page almost entirely blank and
just says um reference fun facts about
strawberry shortcake but no facts about
the strawberry shopkin
then he printed it out again the second
time same page then he printed out the
second page which is simply pictures of
a fat man stood in front of a gas unit
he did that twice
then he's taken away some of the
information now it's just the fat man in
front of the gas unit
okay he's done that twice
[Laughter]
then we move on to information about the
key lime pie so
hey john
who knew johnny clue's job was so hot
[Laughter]
no wonder he's always getting things
wrong specifically so there's absolutely
nothing here about the strawberry
shortcake for me it's just about the key
lime pie but i don't know if you guys
say it in the states um when someone is
offering to either pour the tea or the
coffee or cut a cake do you guys say
shall i be mother you guys say that oh
well billy what shall i be mother yes
please loved it right i'll tell you
something about a strawberry shortcake
uh it's the most famous dessert made
with shortcake there yeah
sliced strawberries are mixed with sugar
and allowed to sit for an hour or so
until the strawberries have surrendered
a great deal of the juices
did you know that a strawberry
surrenders its juices yeah well there
you are the shortcakes are split at the
bottom and covered with a layer of
strawberries juice what
yes yes we're going to start with we'll
just we'll put a slice on each that's
all right
i was reading about a key lime pie
i was like doesn't sound like key lame
play
anyway i love when people shout stuff
out from the audience from a distance
and you have no idea what the candidate
follows
because that doesn't seem to be much on
the uh the strawberry shortcake
key lime pie is an american dessert pie
made of key lime juice egg yolks and
condensed milk
you love condensed milk i love condensed
milk
to the point that if we ever make
anything with condensed milk i'll just
sit and eat the condensed milk
i'm trying to check that with a guy with
a red hat is that an applause or not
eating condensed milk out there yeah
oh well we want to get my dad on the
show don't we at some point because my
dad
is not only a fan of um
show and dilly and lord the rings and
all those kind of things the reason why
i knew about the rings when i was a kid
was my dad
he loves a little tin of condensed milk
oh so do i don't unfortunately my dad's
moving into a diabetic lifestyle so we
might not
attach you know
it's maybe not the best thing i would
check that with your um your doctor but
i wouldn't think that's the best thing
to eat
thanks dumb
thank you
key limes are a bit more tart and more
aromatic than the common persian lime
seen year-round at grocery stores in the
united states key lime juice unlike
regular lime juice it's pale yellow
yep oh agree
the filling in a key lime pie is also
yellow largely because of the egg yolks
i've had a key lime pie before never had
a strawberry shortcake before i did film
an episode of
my next show wild things in florida look
at all thangs yes
looking for
sharks swimming with sharks and we went
down to key west and we did a section
where a guy
cooked for oh or made for us a key lime
pie and what i liked about the key lime
pie the most was just how simple it is
to make really you're just stirring
together all those ingredients and
letting it set really aren't yours
an idiot can do it
it's good that you mentioned that don
because i have some facts on that great
during mixing a reaction between the
protein and the eggs the condensed milk
and the acidic lime juice occurs that
causes the filling to thicken on its own
without requiring baking
early resting there's no bacon in it
it's baking
early recipes for key lime pie did not
require baking the pie relying on this
chemical reaction which is called
thickening
to produce the proper consistency of the
filling today though consuming raw eggs
can be dangerous
pies of this nature are now usually
baked for a short time baking also
thickens the texture
more than the reaction alone do you know
if this cake has been baked or is it
done
we don't know do we um but we were
talking the other week about the fact
that um
in england in britain
we don't tend to keep our eggs in the
fridge because obviously chickens don't
keep their eggs in the fridge
and uh the eggs seem to be all right
and i actually went to someone's house
the other day who had a chicken coop
and um
i said so you don't put the eggs in the
fridge and she said no
with organic chickens organic organic
eggs obviously you don't put them in the
um
fridge because the chickens after they
lay them
roll them in a kind of dust that is
around in the chicken coop and that
keeps them in some way
preserved for like a month or so and
then you had told me that in the states
they go through a chemical process where
you have to put them in the fridge
do you ever listen to the friendship
onion i don't
know because we went through this i do
actually yeah yeah and as in america
they they do something with them right
to kind of clean them and that takes off
the
dust the dust no it's not a dust oh i
don't think it's absolutely you said it
was like a coverage
a coffee hold on
it's a
filament well if you're going to give us
let's give us it on the mic sir come on
that says uh that is an audio it's an
audio show
this is our wonderful security guard
who's been helping us all we can
introduce and also a chicken farmer like
things
actually yes um my name is dalton um
pleasure to meet everybody thank you
so
when they lay it
and it comes out a filament is already
on it and when you take it out it will
last for a month but actually if you put
it in the fridge and this with the
filament on it you can actually keep it
for up to two to three months wow and
the reason they coat the reason it goes
through a washing process and why
there's only white eggs sold in stores
except for the brown ones which cost
more because they're fully organic
is due to some chemicals that were on it
from the late 80s that caused the
sickness and it really wasn't it wasn't
the outside fault it was actually the
inside's fault then from feet but
the fda made the role and it's very hard
to reverse fda rules in the us because
it takes literally an act of congress
that's also very challenging here
so
yeah that's why so there's a filament on
the egg when it comes out to check in
because somebody got sick once in
america
something around feet feed to fetus what
feet was it you said
no feet no feet no feet it was just it
was just something to do with what the
chickens were fed at the time and what
they had ate so it's in the egg
not the filament
but now we wash the filament off which
means you have to put it in the fridge
exactly thank you dalton
[Applause]
i mean to be to be honest in listening
to the wonderful dalton there i kind of
feel like i was pretty much
totally accurate he never once said dust
[Laughter]
dust dusted filament
well should we try it what are you
starting with well i'll start with
whatever you start with
i read an interesting fact here willian
online pie the annual key lime pie
festival started in key west florida in
2002. it's held every year over the july
4th weekend and is a celebration of the
uses of key lime in foods drinks and
cultures i was going to say a better key
lime is good in a little tequila
sunrise
lovely you're ready to look key lime pie
here we go
that was my breakfast actually
billy and i
are very fastidious eaters but on the
show i'd like to um
to get our mouths really close in fact
this is a great way to test this theory
i would say half the audience
dislike
the mastication noises
and half the audience seems to enjoy it
so make sure should we put that to your
vote
as a show of hands who likes the fact
that billy and i overly chew on the mic
well let's not do it as hands it's an
audio thing let's do it as a oh
you couldn't everyone anyone who likes
the noises of billy and itunes just
shout out the word filament
yeah
ready three two one
and anyone who doesn't like it if you
could shout out dust
three two one
we gotta start making noises will you
stop eating them to that mate
the audience have spoken
uh i'm gonna have one more bite of the
key lime pie because to be you know what
it's one of my favorite words to
describe it i would describe it as
moorish well i don't know because
whoever's made this has put some
cinnamon in there
i don't like cinnamon i can barely taste
the cinnamon to be honest so that's
really tainted oh enjoyment of that i'm
i think if we were to if we were to um
kind of learn anything based on this
live podcast moving forward
um
let's just check that again if you like
it filament three two one
if you don't like it dust
oh god
you said we should eat unto them it's
your idea i did i thought it was funny
but i guess it's disgusting more than
funny
should we try the strawberry shortcake
yeah i'm going to keep eating under my
tongue yeah
now was there not and i'm sure uh
this might be more of a question
possibly for the ladies in the audience
although maybe some of the men was there
not a character like a like a cartoon
character called strawberry shortcake is
that correct
and what was her vibe was she made of
strawberry shortcake or something
so it's like a world in which our main
characters are in some way influenced by
the characteristics of cakes
ah and strawberry shortcake was like
cute and sweet and okay who was the bad
guy in strawberry shortcake was it like
chocolate dessert
oh that's lovely that's fantastic have
you tried this shortcake bills was there
a key line pie person in this what what
was key lime healing like key link
kind of sarcastic
what
wow
red hat guy what do you think of this
for memories of the 80s i'm giving a
biggie
but what about the strawberry farmers
well have you tried the strawberry
shortcake hold on john it fell off
trying to strawberry shortcake now
i think
i think we should get a guest up to help
us with this one tom
and see you figure out who is i'm going
to do a little quiz and whoever gets
closest right brilliant who wants to be
involved in this quiz to help us settle
this dom yeah i'm going to get you to
pick the people with their hands up and
whoever gets closest to
the largest ever strawberry shortcake
was in 2012 at the pasadena strawberry
festival now
how many pounds of strawberries did that
cake have in it
tom you pick three people answer that
well we'll have
we'll have this lovely lady here sat on
on the floor right
and we'll have this gentleman hearing in
spectacles if you could get to the make
and we'll have this young lady here
really reaching your hands do one more
dog
get bored and one more
and then
we'll have this lady here doing this
with her fingers yes you my dear yes
that's four people lovely if you'd like
to come over to the mic that'd be great
in the 2012 pasadena strawberry festival
the world's largest strawberry shortcake
was made the cake contained how many
pounds of strawberries yes number one my
dear
four hundred
four hundred okay good pounds okay just
move to this if you'd like to note that
down down 100 yes
[Laughter]
next guess please 145 145.
2.99
299.
okay i'm going big
eight hundred pounds you say
the size of a small rhinoceros
william the answer is two cows and a
fight
the kick used
three thousand two hundred and forty
pounds of strawberries
my darling come over and come on do we
have an extra plate anywhere come on we
must have a a clean and fresh plate that
way
all right we're having two come on
we can't let people down
tom you i told you to write it down with
your knife can we have one more plate
please could you come on this side
now what is the names of the people we
have on stage now could you see them
into the mic you come over could you
come over this side and we'll keep it
perpendicular
elemental
um
great so uh what was your name i'm becky
where's that where's that
tampa do you know i used to work uh for
a living before i did this
uh and and i gave it up and and i said
i'm gonna go to florida and live in
florida like
like when i was like 21 years old i
don't even know what i was thinking and
i went to the floor of the keys and i
just lived there for like three months
bombing around doing nothing weird right
but my for my first choice as a young
man where he lived was florida so
must be something in it
[Applause]
right here we go so we're going to get
this answer for ron desantis
what should be then the state cake yes
ladies
okay so that was the key lime pie by
both ladies
you could use attack
i think it's delicious but i'll eat
anything sweet i think oh okay all right
strawberry shortcake
actually my thing with flavor just in
general yeah is
i like stuff that
really kind of
knocks my boots off do you know what i
mean i'm not a fan
of like bland stuff that is filling or
nutritious or that's not necessarily
good for you i've always lent towards
like
southeast asian food spicy food food
that makes you go whoa have a reaction
nothing nothing subtle nothing so and
your fashion
your hairstyles
ain't nothing nothing
uh what's the word um
what's that word about the thing in
between no no
mediocre
yeah right okay
are we giving it marks or are we just
saying what is it what should be
the cake which should we give it mark we
should probably give it match because
that's what we normally okay okay
so first off we'll do a key lime pie
marks out a 10 for flavor
a nine
lovely gg
nine or nine even though it needed a
little bit more tang
but only one little bit of tang to make
it
okay great do you make a key lime pie
yourself do you have it
okay
oh good well that's just half the battle
really
dom i can really only give that a six
because i don't i don't like that
cinnamon in there ah your ability to
spot cinnamon is profound because i can
barely taste any cinnamon in there it's
my superpower yeah your cinnamon
sensitive ah i'm i liked it as well i'm
gonna give it an 8.8 i enjoyed it yeah i
enjoy and what do you about as
aesthetics how does it look how does it
look after i've murdered it with a knife
yeah just kind of like a blob so it
didn't look
the most appetizing so maybe like a five
so five over here john yeah lovely gg a
one a one
i think i'm with the ladies on this one
i would have liked my key lime pie to
maybe show off a little bit of a key
limey thing maybe having a greenish hue
it's not enough just to stick a lame on
top now it's not
really oh oh so uh i'm gonna give it
yeah i'll give it a four three
[Music]
and then
i mean that was billy's category but
dessert's always useful so 10.
wow that's a 10 for useful but can you
do it and else with it can you make
anything else with it could you make a
soup
it's definitely one of the things that
you can bring to a gathering a party an
event a gala
a fate
um
okay chocolate covered key lime on it
like a lollipop
okay
so
oh there's a few uses okay oh hang on
you men yes
a paint yeah you can put your pie a key
lime pie in someone's face
that's a good call actually well
usefulness then gigi usefulness
would be good yeah so out of 10
usefulness what do you think well maybe
it's six six yeah that's good um i can
only give it a three again oh okay yeah
i'll say like a five for usefulness
right let's go on in a strawberry
shortcake
which is a character as we've all went
uh flavor and or taste
flavor and orton
oh hang on jeez he's not happy come on
describe that cake as claggy
i find it claggy
it's uh it's it's creating more of a
closer relationship between the bottom
and the top of my mouth which i don't
like
it's becoming one i'm going to give it a
yeah i don't like it for flavor um i'll
give it a two
yeah i was gonna say it too it just
tastes like a normal yellow cake the
only strawberry is the little pink part
and then on top there
yeah yeah it's not it doesn't have
enough strawberry in there and how's it
shortcake
is it showcase it's not even a proper
strawberry sugar
failed
i wanted them to chop up a little bit of
the fruit and maybe put it in the cake
itself yeah that would be nice wouldn't
it done i
hang on everyone's talking at the same
time no it's okay
ah so you you guys are not feeling it
you're not feeling the shortcake
the juices weren't surrendered says
jesus i think that's the main problem
that that might be the new title of our
album
[Applause]
the juices weren't surrendered
brilliant um that might be my epitaph
actually here lies dominic monaghan his
juices weren't surrendered
um what now oh aesthetics how does it
look how does it look um i mean it looks
pretty so
i mean
i changed my mind maybe like a five
five jj six six
i can't remember what i scored the key
lime pie for looks does anyone remember
it wasn't
high
it doesn't three or four you know i
would say actually looks slightly better
than the key lime pie so i'm gonna give
it a
six point seven um i can only give that
five dough
right so hold on whoever's bought the
cakes for us today has really failed on
the strawberry parfait
usefulness
oh gosh that's hard um
i don't think it's very useful
well i guess i'll give it a two as well
it's a two 10 to the other one because
it was delicious yeah you liked it yeah
so but okay i'll just stick with the two
so two
g a one one oh not very useful i mean
like your little men said over there you
can certainly stick this cake in your
face as well oh yeah again someone's
face out usefulness oh yeah i'll give it
a 2.2
yeah i can't give it much for usual dumb
there's not much you could do with that
i'll give it a three
guys the clear winner the clear winner
is the key lime pie
[Applause]
so if anyone knows the office of ron de
santos if you could write to him and say
you'd like him to reconsider
what has been done in a scientific way
there's no more scientific we could be
other than getting the correct
strawberry cake
ladies thank you for joining us if you'd
like to take your cake i've got it
everywhere you can take it with you
um but thank you gigi
and the wonderful nameless woman
becky
i think becky's got a question is it
hold on it's a quick question that's a
quick question you guys talk about music
a lot so i was wondering what your
favorite britney spears song is
well i don't know if you guys have heard
billy's incredible version of hit me
baby one more time oh
[Applause]
sings like a lark he does lovely
entertainment yeah
that has to be my favorite that is a
classic song yeah that's a good one
what's the one where she's on a plane
and she's wearing something toxic kind
of makes it look like a jelly bean
um
toxic i like that one and um wait oh the
one with a snake oh she's a slave for
someone i think i'm a slave
yeah
there you go ladies thanks thank you
thank you thank you round of applause
for the lovely ladies i love it
you can keep peak if you want or maybe
whatever you want hey billy what job
we're getting we're getting told that
we've probably got like a minute and a
half left or something like that what
are you doing i've destroyed my cake
and to be to be honest you and i talked
a little bit at the start about how to
start the podcast and at no point did we
um
get into how to end it so in real time
have you got any oh well i would think
we
opened doors and
we tell everyone to get the hell out and
we'll just stay here and eat some key
lime pie should we do you think that
would work do you think people would
believe it was over
if we just sat and said
that's it
is that no it really is
[Laughter]
you can leave me
[Music]
all right well
we could put pies in each other's face
but we have to work for the rest of the
day
i guess we should say thank you guys all
for coming no that set down
[Applause]
it's been brilliant and we will always
billy and i will always remember
[Music]
billy and i will always remember the
audience that came to the first ever
live friendship we will always love you
the most thank you very much thank you
florida
thank you key lame pie
thank you britney spears
thank you dom
thanks bill thank you see you later
thank you for coming guys brilliant
[Music]
with me and hold me tight all through
the night you're shining bright i'm your
host the baby you're my
[Music]